like you know for 50 years
it makes me sound old but in my head i
think i'm 20. so
as long as you keep that in mind you
never you never get home
i kido you know you can listen but i
talk to the new people aikido either you
get it or you don't that's the way i see
it i've done tai chi
yoga meditation
i do healing work i do all sorts of
things
but somehow i kedo i can't quite get it
so i keep going
and and my training really nowadays is
teaching
because i'm working more on the subtle
things and at my level just a few
centimeters you know a few centimeters
out
to make the whole difference whether it
will work or not work
uh the different stages from beginner
all the way up through the blackouts
they can make lots of errors but still
think they're making it work
and the person falls down and you think
oh i must have got it i like that
techniques i must have got it where
really the higher you get the more you
realize that in the end
if you can take a piece of tracing paper
and pull it through the gap
that's about as close as you need to
really get it so it's very
it's a it's a martial art that is for i
think for perfectionists and with a
perfectionist you'll never perfect it so
that means you can keep doing it till
you die
with your partner
and for many years you'll do it
and
not really get much happiness because
the teacher shows you to do it
so you just keep doing it
but in the end you realize
that this is like the letter a
of the alphabet
it's actually the most important
part
like you know is dominion
why is that
i'm already connected with him you know
if we could see horrors and energies
just by putting my hand out there
i'll automatically connect with him well
before he gets to me
i stimulate
the from the toe
to the hands
i then
my hands are going in his direction but
he's having this direction so i have to
couple up and make this shape so now my
fingers are going in his direction
that's the direction of his energy
so at my level that's what i'm thinking
about i'm thinking more about the
flow
of movement than i
am then i have to move him you know if i
hold
you
and give him a hundred percent in the
grip
he's got overcome that somehow one day
he's got to overcome it okay